in einer partnerschaft ist es wichtig
dass man sich gegenseitig respektiert
und wertgeschätzt und solche dinge
dürfen einfach nicht passieren
bist du von damals baum gefallen ich
will ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
aussprechen hilf mir
wir hatten heute reagieren wir
allerdings nicht zusammen auf eine für
alle zugängliche kostenlose folge hilft
mir auf 'youtube' nein ich habe für
diese folge die wir uns heute anschauen
tatsächlich vier euro 99 bezahlt
wahrscheinlich sind deine eltern nicht
zufrieden
die reagieren heute gemeinsam auf die
folge die verkohlte barbie und ich würde
sagen wir fangen direkt an mit der
scheiße
[Musik]
wir sind eher bei sekunde 1 und das
allererste was man sieht ist das die
folge natürlich in meiner heimat mal
wieder gedreht wird
die 18-jährige klarer arbeitet in einem
sonnenstudio und ist selbst ihre beste
kundin
diese einfach nackt dkv werbe
freundlichkeit hat die 18-jährige klare
arbeitet in einem sonnenstudio und sie
jetzt selbst die größte solarium kunden
das kann nicht gesund sein begann alles
in ordnung bei dir
[Musik]
da merkt man wirklich will dass wir sie
mit den besten der besten schauspieler
zu tun haben
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass wir dem video jetzt alle
meine daumen hoch gibt und main kanal
abonniert dafür dass ich hier fünf euro
für diese gequirlte chaos gegeben habe
und mir das jetzt hier auch noch
komplett anschauen werde
es ist vollkommen verbrannt du siehst
aus wie ein krebs ich bin so oft es zu
verbrannt aussiehst und jugendliche
sie waren von dort kam war das einzige
sicherheitsproblem was sie herumläuft
dass sowohl du selbst
die sie als problem der tiroler wird er
wohl wieder denn wo du selber das muss
ich mir nicht gleich lassen
wir gehen auf die bank aber das ist
richtig erkennt dich gar nicht wieder
seitdem du mit diesen wie heißt er
nochmal dieser komische lieder zu
schreiben wenn ich nur weil du so bist
und kann kerner bekommst meine güte
aha
klarer geht anscheinend so oft ins
solarium minister dann auch immer so
lange in dem raum weil sie sich da
selbstverständlich den oli klären will
oli kahn will die will die haben und oli
pocher wahrscheinlich beide alice immer
noch unter den verbrennungen zu leiden
dann kann es ja ich weiss nicht ihr
einziges ins gesicht mit quark maske
gemacht quarkmasse menschen nicht gesund
ziemlich abstoßend rektor nicht so
kurzawa bruder michael kors so oft bei
dir ja aber gut ist ja dass ich heute
ohne ihren achtzigsten geburtstag nicht
durch schminken muss die bahn gehe ich
ins fitnessstudio machen was für meine
figur
aha
mit molly ins fitnessstudio anderen ort
wo ihr zusammen gut regieren könnte da
die mutter hat hier schon den richtigen
instinkt dass richtung mitwelt
therapeutin der einzige hypno den ich
kenne das von pokémon entscheiden uns
früher so gut verstanden
sie haben ja alles erzählt der seite die
mit diesem alles zusammen es macht ja
gar nichts mehr geht
[Musik]
mit oli ich dachte sie will ihnen nur
beeindrucken irgendwie mit ihrer bäume
und will sich ihnen dann kleider bock
erscheinen sind sie schon per du ist
somit der studie nehmen wenn man ein
bisschen kalorien verbrennen ich vor dem
training auf der rückbank
wenn euch jemand wieder ins gedächtnis
dass ich fünf euro
diese schein bezahlt habe wie sieht's
heute abend 80 geburtstag kommt auch
vorbei
die mutter von der klarer ist wohl so
hey wir haben wir da am familie treffen
kommen mithin aber der mann von der
mutter also der vater von der klage
ich weiß nicht wo das hier alles noch
hinführen soll und drei sauberen gott
3com anscheinend hast zwei wegen wollen
wie das aussieht wenn ich so eine kleine
dicke freundin hab ja gott super geht
braucht hast vielleicht das minus zu
trinken so ganz alleine deshalb training
oder so die tage ja klar machen termin
okay ich hätte wirklich gedacht zu
beginn der folge dass mir keine personen
und sympathischer werden kann als klar
ab aber er diese pink lady er hat es auf
jeden fall immer wieder den spaß dann
vom toten gebirge gehauen
guck doch mal je gefühl hatte tags also
noch alle ich habe ganz normale der
gerät das der kunde was soll ich denn
machen
kunde ist könig bei mir weißt du früher
saß im zimmer nichts gemacht bücher
gelesen heute tut sie was geht raus
macht sich schäfer ihren freund findest
du es nicht toll
die geschichte meiner kollegen sehr
ähnlich zu dem hier noch pässen anholt
und übertreibt man nicht spricht damit
ein
mit dem zusammen die dich nehmen wenn er
nicht haben kann kinder weil unser dorf
für die mädels oder also ganz ehrlich du
wirst am ende sehen wer von uns beiden
klar machte
jetzt muss wissen fahrservice gehört zu
meinen diensten als personal trainer
dazu ich rufe dich haben wir trainieren
zusammen wie abgemacht junge deine
aufgabe ist es schön auszusehen und den
mund zu halten
[Musik]
die standardaufgaben einer frau laut dem
lieben olli fitnessstudio besucher
kommen auch hier bin ist allerdings hier
machen in einer partnerschaft ist es
wichtig dass man sich gegenseitig
respektiert und wertgeschätzt und solche
dinge dürfen einfach nicht passieren
bist du von damals baum gefallen oder
[Musik]
gerade noch diese hypnotherapie was
westlich von der festnahme ist sie
lagerte gerade auch einen von wegen ja
in der partnerschaft da muss man
respektieren und da ist wichtig und
gegeneinanders vom baum gefallen oder
was aber freunde jetzt schauen wir mal
ins personal trading von dem oli mit
seinem flittchen da rein läuft das ist
ein bisschen das kommt doch kein sei
sehr schön tief gestern die das schöne
das training kann nicht hart genug seien
das training ist nicht das einzige was
rat wenn du so weitermachst zwar gleich
meine lange nutzen
[Musik]
doch nicht sagen wow aion wird immer mit
die schlimmste gewalt
die folge war jetzt zu beginn schon
fremdscham pur aber die hat sich so
langsam immer weiter gesteigert
die werke sind jedoch schlimmer werden
ich stehe auf langen hanteln und ich
bock hast ich habe im büro macht ist
ganz großen klar nein ich bin mit ihr
ein paar verträge durchgegangen
[Musik]
an der stelle an der stelle meine lieben
zuschauer will ich das heutige video
meine reaktion auf diese hilfen ihr
folge die verkohlte barbie nun auch
beenden weil ich kann mir diese
fremdscham queens kacke ehrlich gesagt
wirklich nicht mehr geben ich habe fünf
euro dafür aus getätigt hat schon nicht
mehr reden wenn ich via klarer und
oliver bringt mich noch ins grab
ein rating gefallen hat das unbedingt
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da ich verlinke euch die folge selbst
entstand hier und in der video
beschreibung ist kostet wie gesagt der
hat wenn ihr euch die anschauen wollte
aber ihr könnt mir immer gerne in die
kommentare schreiben
ob ich eventuell in einer woche mit dem
rest der folge anschauen soll denn ich
bin gerade erst bei minute 26 von 43
wenn ich mir den rest doch anschauen
soll der nächste wegziehen und abonniert
gern mal ein kanal
falls sie abonnent seit liegt ja noch
die glocke dann bekommt ihr eine
benachrichtigung sobald ein neues video
online geht und ich jetzt meinen
fremdscham mal auskotzen
[Musik]